test one test tube there's
three good afternoon so there's
always a lesson the lesson is
hisses.
Places been beautifully set up
for us but they forgot new
batteries.
And I think that's a good
reminder make sure you have
batteries make sure you a fresh
water -- In
a whole lot of other things --
Just to it for life in general
but certainly.
Here in our community where --
We have experienced just some
extraordinary --
Challenges and disasters over
the last six months and so I
want to thank.
All of you and welcome all of
you here today as well as those
who are joining us.
Via live stream --
And I do believe there is so
large --
Representation out there in the
ether who are.
A concern that are participating
and I want to thank all of you
who are here today.
Offer joining up.
I'm state senator Hannah Beth
Jackson I represent the
nineteenth state Senate
district.
Which is all of Santa Barbara
county and all of western
Ventura county --
Through --
High Santa Paula and Fillmore
and all the way up.
Kim Rio to the top of the Kaneko
grade and up in this direction
so.
The districts are only about a
hundred and every amber that
fire.
Other Tom aspirant every
incident we've had in this area
is in not only the nineteen
Senate district but the thirty
seventh the simply districts so.
My culture assembly member
Monique cling we moan and I are
joined at the hip.
Literally and figuratively up
and I was thinking the other day
--
Our first bonding moment came
during the time we're having
those terrible range --
And we both needed to be here so
we rented a truck.
And drove down from Sacramento
think it took nine and a half
hours.
And we wish we were.
Stupid to do this C. it was a
very dangerous trip but we
needed to get home and and of
course we've been --
Side by side during the Thomas
fire and we're so we're going to
brief when.
C. are --
Holiday fire so --
It's it's an honor for me to be
able to share the stage with
her.
And Dodd to be your your state
senator I know we've all been
through a lot [inaudible]
And hopefully we are moving out
of it but the the fire that we
had last week in his reminder
that we must always be vigilant.
That -- We
are.
Only.
Get a bit a lot away from having
events that are again going to
challenge our our community but
we have a spirit here.
Are members --
Being here about six months ago
people who had just been through
the debris flow --
And seeing us come together
really is inspiring --
And we have and we will continue
to do so as we all have our
hearing today --
We've entitled a vision for
Santa Barbara recovery and
rebuild evaluating where we are
now.
The long term plan for
revitalizing our community.
And ensuring continued effective
collaboration going forward for
whatever the challenges are in
the disasters that may befall
us.
Being strong togethers community
working with our public
officials in our community --
We will continue to overcome and
the strength and a by the
lessons that we learned.
So the purpose of today's
hearing is to assemble key
leaders from both the local and
state level.
A to update this community on
the efforts that are being taken
in both Sacramento.
And of Santa Barbara for the
long term rebuilding and
revitalization of the county.
Of Monning and of I think that.
By the fact we're here.
We had an incident last Friday
our discussions about.
Doing something that seemed
appropriate after six months who
made even more important --
By this fired this past weekend
which sadly took thirteen homes
and a number of additional
buildings.
But with a without the loss of
life and that of course is
always the critical and most
important thing.
And the fact that we up that
are.
Public safety or fire department
Skinner with lessons learned
they knew it with a red flag
warning that there was a real
potential for fire and there's
no doubt.
That having these fire trucks
from other parts of the state or
local folks everybody all hands
on deck.
Kept that far from getting worse
than than it was in and then it
could have been so.
With nine far out thousand
wildfires ignited across all
parts of the strip state last
year which was no worse fire --
Wildfire year we've had this
year looks like it's going to be
as bad if not worse --
We burned over --
Half a million acres of land
last year destroyed more than
ten thousand eight hundred
structures.
And claimed the lives of seventy
one people --
And we of course here in in this
county were among the most
impacted their communities in
the state first with the Thomas
fire which also.
Impacted our friends and
colleagues in Ventura --
Took out about five hundred
eighty six homes in.
One strip of fought area in
Ventura took out homes in the
Ohio valley --
And then of course --
Damaged --
About a thousand homes when we
the debris flow --
We've had our share of problems
so -- We're
here today to talk about --
Where we are in terms of that
rebuilt our resiliency what
we're gonna do going forward the
county has been gracious enough
to give?
It's their time to be here in
the state we also have.
A a number of people
representing the state of who
are with us.
You know the frequency of these
natural disasters reflects would
get a brown and others have been
talking about is the new normal.
Climate change is real.
And does the fact that we have
gone through years of drought
that our weather fans have been
so much more dramatic whether
it's here in California through
or around the country or world.
A we have we saw when we had
that debris flow the humidity --
During the fire rather in and as
said to be flow was --
Creating a the lowest humidity
rates that's why the fire burned
as it did it when it started it
was burning at the rate of an
acre [inaudible]
Second.
Think about that acre a set.
And the night of the debris flow
because we have pre positioned
--
So many of our public safety
people nine hundred people.
Out were saved the night of the
debris flow.
So we lost.
Twenty three there were nine
hundred other people who are
sick because of the work that
was done in anticipation.
Of this potential problem we
have to maintain that vigilance
and I am confident that.
With your help with the help of
the experts who are here and
good government and that really
is this is government at its
finest people coming together.
Recognizing the challenges that
we have and working out together
to make sure we are.
Attacked it as we possibly can.
And finally assembly member Lee
Monning I after we hear from
both of our local community
where we are in has everyone
picked up a young [inaudible]
An agenda.
So that you at least here no --
Where we're going to start and
perhaps assembly member will it
remind everyone who is at home
and not if not?
I able to follow with the
agenda.
Of who were all gonna be
speaking at the end assembly
member.
Are going to follow up with
legislative update on the work
that we've been doing in the
budget efforts.
You know part of the challenge
when you start rebuilding is
where's the money.
And of course we'll have someone
talking about the insurance
challenges for private property
owners but the state has really
tried to step in the federal
government stepped in to help us
--
With data of recovery in rebuilt
at and yet there's a lot more to
do so with that I want to hand
--
The microphone with new
batteries over to assembly
member of the Monning for
opening remarks.
Thank you senator and I think
you all for being here --
There is a and number of you
that are here that been in touch
with us throughout this.
I'm.
I think process throughout the
moments that our communities
have been living when we decided
to move forward with having this
hearing.
We did it with the purpose of
wanting to bring a little of the
work that we do in Sacramento to
you locally.
I'm we've had hearings in
Sacramento related to natural
disasters to response to
recovery and some of you in the
room have been able to J.. For
those on but we wanted to ensure
the you had the opportunity to
be here to listen and that we
have the opportunity to hear
from you.
And really the goal of this
hearing is simply that and this
will be part of our legislative
record and it's being recorded
it's being life tell about aids
it's been at televised on
online.
I and additionally each of us in
our respective legislative
houses chairs a committee that
rectally addresses the issues
that we have lived that we
continue to live and made.
Continue to live in the future
--
In terms of natural disasters in
response and recovery I do want
to recognize on as has been said
that the work we do we don't do
alone.
And we do collaborative Lee with
individuals with entities with
bodies of government and with.
Private and public partnerships
to understand how.
And I and there is a
representative here from Soviet
Carvajal's office Chris Hansen
on who is here representing our
Congress member thank you for
being here.
On the county supervisor das
Williams who is here and win M.
grief from the school board who
you'll hear from I'm in.
It's moments and so these are
some of the elected offices as
well as a lot of our public
safety offices that you'll hear
from but I wanted to recognize
that the work we're doing.
Is not them alone and this is
part of one part of me convert.
I happen out you don't expect
that today we will walk away
with all the answers or
solutions onto these to the
magnitude of problems that we've
seen.
We do expect that this is one
piece of a puzzle that
dachshunds onto a better
solution to a better
understanding of the issues that
our community is going.
Up through and the ways that we
can address them within our
roles as in the state we have
some capacity to address some
but that's not the only area are
only space where these if it can
be addressed.
And so I want to recognize that
thank you for being here and
thank you for being a part of
this conversation.
On and also let you know that
this is at this may be the first
formal hearing that we are
having here but it is not our
only opportunity to engage we
will continue to have these
conversations.
Both of our offices are open to
continue the discussion and I'm
by the end of the hearing you
will also.
Better hopefully better
understood where our office can
be of help.
And with that I would do one
invite to people to you I just
give welcoming remarks and to
people who have been out really
tea and allowing us to be here
today -- And
the first is Anthony rainy brown
who is the superintendent up for
our money C. to union school
district who have had the
pleasure of working with.
And to give some opening remarks
and then we will move over to
our county C. L. I'm on M..
My if Saddam.
Thank you very much once again
my name is Anthony rained I. and
it's my pleasure to welcome you
Tamana sido union school and
this is our auditorium where
happy to have you here.
You know we have a few different
models at mansio union school
that we use.
And to whom I'd like to share
with you one of them is --
Stronger together.
And the second one is we got
this.
Yeah during the debris flow in
the Tom to fire I think this
community had both those models
as a community models as well.
We all did our part we're
stronger together we're all we
all did our part during the
disaster and then in the
aftermath.
And here mama C. no union school
we certainly try to do our part
to be stronger together we where
the site for water distribution
the site first sandbag filling
we've been the site for
community meetings and insurance
meetings and meetings with
contractor's.
Because we feel that a strong
minus Edo makes a strong mind
aceto union school.
And we also have the model of we
got this and as dark as things
got we thought that --
Everybody in this community
paint optimistic and I hope that
today will continue --
To I look at the stark realities
but also be optimistic because
mama Seto has a bright future.
I also wanna M. really happy to
be here today to be able to
think senator Jackson and
assembly mentor live moaned for
their amazing leadership but if
we can thank the M. please for
everything that they've done.
And specifically for public
schools both of them really went
to bat for us in Sacramento to
get a I. I. property tax back
Phil from the state of
California. To make public
school districts whole both in
this fiscal year and the next
fiscal year because along with
everything else property taxes
are are likely to go down and
that's gonna affect our revenue.
But these folks up here on the
diet's really the whole why
worry we in the rebuilding
process so again thank you for
for that leadership --
At finally I have someone very
important announcements where
the bathrooms are --
And so if you need to use the
facilities come out here to our
beautiful courtyard and take the
ramp or the steps down stairs
and you'll see bathrooms clearly
marked there's water bottles I'm
in the front.
And there's a water bottle
filled --
Filling station around the back
in case you need more so I once
again welcome Tamana Seto union
school and here's to making
money Seto ever stronger thank
you.
Good afternoon everyone I
Monning your site of the county
executive officer for the county
Santa Barbara and again welcome
and I also want to thank
assembly member LeMond and
tender Jackson --
They were with us even before
the debris flow as the Thomas
fire was approaching our
boundaries in our borders there
with us communicating with us
asking what we needed to and
preparations we appreciate.
Their time they are continuing
to lend their assistance and
their staffs assistance to us
throughout the whole period.
And many people don't know that
they're actually with us almost
daily --
Either in a in person or on the
phone in our EEOC during that
time as well as our first
district supervisor um dos
Williams and members of
supervisor car I'm.
Congressman Carvajal staff.
And they're with us on the phone
or in person every day in the
weeks following the day's Apollo
to help us and make sure that we
are getting what we are needed.
And I have proof of that because
I'm not lost five pounds I
gained from all the donuts they
brought in every single time
they came in so thank you for
that [inaudible]
Home.
Well you're gonna hear today is
our approach.
The key Monticello way of
recovery and all disasters or
local I think what this has
shown us is that this is really
been experience.
Of neighbors working with
neighbors.
And residents working with
county government.
And we know we can't do it
alone.
And we've relied on and continue
to rely on the smarts and the
skills and the vigor and energy.
Of monitor residents
philanthropists and non profits
to make all of this recovery
work for all of us --
It's also been led buy art the
board dos Williams.
Who he and his little girl he C.
at all the different community
means have been?
Propelling us forward and making
sure that this community is
getting all the resources of the
county can bring to bear.
I'm where you're gonna hear on
our discussed recovery plan
that's going to be presented to
you by Matt Pontus --
My assistant county executive
officer who I've dedicated to
the recovery effort.
On for the last six months and
will continue.
Is about our plan.
Which emphasizes resiliency and
understanding the uniqueness of
Monticello.
Plants focus is on the
fundamental that is I. county
government can do and can bring
to bear.
Within our purview that we can
actually catalyze it contains an
array of actions them at will
discuss but it's basically
focused on how to reduce.
Future risks how we prepare. For
the next disaster how can we
enable residents to rebuild as
quickly as possible and some of
you were at the meeting
yesterday.
Discussing --
The new FEMA maps the County
Board of supervisors adopted
this plan on June fifth
unanimously.
In our county recovery team
meets every week to drive that
plan and make sure we're meeting
all those tasks and activities
on time.
This is still one of the highest
priorities for county
government.
About other things.
Not just for our chair dos
Williams he's been leading these
efforts.
But for all the county.
So thank you again and without I
believe the first panel is ready
to go and I'll hand it over to
you I believe Matt Pontus once.
Introductions are made.
You very much.
Thank you so much for your
efforts.
Sorry about the donuts but they
really were good --
And and certainly the work that
everybody did you I. fire burned
for forty days --
Really quite extraordinary
unlike any other fire I think
that California's had and
certainly the largest wildfire
in the history of the state.
So we are going to go to our
first panel are current on the
current status of the discovery
recovery plan and for those at
home who don't have.
The agenda we're gonna hear
first from out Pontus the
director of recovery for Santa
Barbara county as chief
executive officer Misato mention
with their gonna hear from Quinn
Laurie.
Of who is a representative of
the partnership for resilient
communities in Wanda's shido
which is a sort of public
private partnership of very
interesting I think creative.
Approach to trying to provide
additional insight into ways
that we can.
Recovering go on and then we
have cheap I. Eric Peterson who
is the for the Santa Barbara
county fire department who will
give us his.
Of use.
Been involved in a number of
these disasters and has some
suggestions and visions that I
think will be helpful and then
Kate ruby.
With the Montesinos center for
prepared building --
Many of you.
Have seen her there this is an
extraordinary community effort
to try to make sure that
everyone has been impacted has a
place to go.
I and can get the assistance
they need dead during these
difficult times so with that
Matt if you'd like to go ahead
[inaudible]
Thank you.
Shade that senator Jackson. To
get a map partis --
Director of recovery here and
I'd like to welcome everybody
here tonight.
We have an action packed --
Agenda for you so I'm gonna go
ahead get started.
Really appreciated some of the
the comments that the
representative from the
superintendent's office.
Talked about when they talk
about structure together.
Because if we look at this
Republic plan this is something
that the county could absolutely
Dodd do alone.
It took a lot of work from a lot
of our partners --
The partnership resilient
communities provided an expert
to us.
That had worked for FEMA and
callow yes that helped us a line
all of our actions toward.
Callaway yes template and FEMA
templates so that we were sure
that we didn't miss anything as
we tried to figure out this
incredible puzzle.
And provide the community of
Mont aceto with all of the tools
that they needed to help getting
back on their feet.
So with that the recovery
strategic plan really is our
efforts that pulled together all
the different disciplines.
And it is not what those
documents that lives on shelves
where.
The action versions D..
One of this plan it and the
short couple months that we've
had because it is change so much
[inaudible]
Return.
And in New I'd come in.
We bring him it would solve Mike
solving puzzles.
And then.
We continue to work for them.
So based upon those kinds of
ideas the plan had to be
flexible had to be very
efficient with our with our
staff time.
That absolutely had dated driven
decisions being made
[inaudible]
We I had the end goal of always
headed towards a more resilient
mosquito community [inaudible]
Exide.
The plant components had
[inaudible]
Eight sections.
Storm preparation evacuation
portion.
A long term flood control
mitigation [inaudible]
Section.
Private property rebuilding.
Debris on private property and
what did there.
Financial impacts an economic
covering section.
Infrastructure repair
modifications.
The natural resources and
cultural section any community
engagement portion [inaudible]
It's like.
With that seven main plan
objectives that the planned
attempted to achieve. To
identify those issues most
important to the recovery.
Develop a planned to solve the
issues.
Sure the public is informed of
the county's efforts.
In the support of money issues
recovery through all means
available.
And that really does mean all
means available other state
federal and private partnerships
all along the way. To engage the
public and our elected
officials.
To determine the best solutions
necessary for recovery
[inaudible]
Slide.
Utilize public and private
partnerships in all of our
recovery efforts. To work with
not profits to provide
assistance where the government
services were able.
To or we didn't have enough
them.
Do you to prepare communities
for futures forms back patients.
The best data available.
You're gonna hear a little bit
about that tonight.
As we look towards another fall
and winter --
Rainy season who wanted to have
the most information available
and make sure that we're clear.
Communicating those evacuations
[inaudible]
Slide.
Yeah last planned objective was
developed plans and strategies
that address the storm
preparation and evacuation. For
the next three to five years.
Until our vegetation regrows.
We have mitigation efforts for
future future debris flows.
Sure we have a rebuilding
process for all different
category is of damaged and droid
properties.
And they were communicating the
strategies the community
[inaudible]
Slide.
I'm through a couple issues the
first one storm preparation
evacuation.
And I should know this report
really is a very thick report
that I'll show you the address
of the very end where you can go
when.
See more depth of the report and
what we're doing today is just a
really high level --
Topic overview --
If any sections as multiple
pages and multiple portions --
Under storm preparation
evacuation are Ted us locally
here.
Is that we're finalizing our
criteria for evacuation
thresholds.
And we know that --
That is really important into
how many folks are going to be
evacuating this winter we had a
lot of resources for John again
data behind those decisions.
And a team of public safety
professionals.
And scientists they're working
together. To to work on that
storm preparation.
We're updating the risk map.
That has a debris flow --
Portion of it as you're all
aware of the hazard maps.
We have a contractor that's
helping us through that.
We're also gonna have starting
in September a large outreach
and education plan.
But we will be back here
hopefully again --
Many times before the rainy
season [inaudible]
Next like.
This slide should look familiar
to a lot of you and this was the
seventy two hour storm
evacuation timeline.
That we used last year.
And so we're gonna be revisiting
that time line for this year
we're gonna be adjusting it.
Will be.
Making sure that the things that
we worked really well continue.
Mendoza is that we need to
improve on that we're gonna
prove what we had a lot of
comments over the last six
months on dates that we could do
better in this area.
And we are taking them all under
advisement [inaudible]
Slot.
Under the long term flood
control mitigation us.
Consultant that's working on
debris based modifications.
We have Mike Corbin appears
that's been analyzing our basin
and our channel capacity.
We have a bunch of hazard
mitigation grant program that's
that acting.
H. M. G. P. up there --
And NY preserve intent and these
are.
Gramps there were going to be
going after.
That -- Help.
Us fund Curt flood control
mitigation in the few
[inaudible]
And we have a lot of information
it'll be coming out on that and
then months ahead.
It will be back in for with one
of our board of supervisors in
late August discuss some of
those --
Medications.
Open those --
And applications all they also
include a future disposal sites.
So we have a place to put the
mud and debris and wanted out.
Should we get further but and
close.
And property acquisition for
flood ease and flood easements.
It's like this.
Every property rebuilding.
This is one of the most
important issues that we took
our over the last few months.
And will we tried to do was put
everything we needed. To put it
together to make.
Sabol for property owners.
Make informed decisions about.
The rebuilding options.
This included identifying and
categorized all impacted
properties are planning and
develop development department.
Together and attractive map that
depicts all of the different --
Statuses of those properties.
Our borders divisors led by
supervisor Dodd Williams.
Bob did a like for like
ordinance.
That was a little more in tune
and flexible with the type of
conditions that exist here in
modest ito.
After the brief low.
Our coastal commission adopted
that like for like ordinance.
De our board of supervisors
adopted the FEMA map that we
talked about last night here at
the community meeting --
Helped give.
Folks --
Their understanding of the
possibilities with flood.
Based upon the current condition
of the vegetate Jim in the hills
--
Behind us here [inaudible]
And we have set up case manager.
And a local team of architects
and engineers to work together
with homeowners. To hopefully
wide forks many options it has
many different Hannah I. is as
possible that help inform them
about their decisions
[inaudible]
It's like.
Is you for was to breeze on
private property.
And as you're all acutely aware
this is been an issue that we've
been struggling within and
working on for romance --
We're still maintain the
materials exchange website
without a lot of really positive
--
Feedback that that --
Lot homeowners were using that.
And being able --
To remove boulders and rocks and
and soil from that.
Our household waste --
Hazardous waste household
hazardous waste pick ups we have
completed to those in the
community the remove those items
from -- The
areas that --
There were hazardous in nature.
We have ongoing work to try and
secure disposal tights.
So that we can quickly move and
debris should we get future --
Storm events [inaudible]
Slide.
Issue five in our recovery
strategic plan.
Dealt more with the financial
impacts and the economic
recovery of our community.
We have a team of folks that are
folks dawn full cost recovery --
Through the set Paris M.
remembers offices they've been
instrumental in helping us with
the property.
Tax backfill from the state of
California [inaudible]
That is.
Critically important it and
given us the tools we have that
we need here locally to do some
of these hazard mitigation.
Projects and other things.
We have thirteen had negation
grant projects [inaudible]
They're submitted. To a total
ask of fifty two million
dollars.
But there would comes with the
local match of over twelve
million dollars --
We have state and federal level
coordination several different
kind of matching funds that were
working through right now.
And we have long term funding
sources need four of the capital
and the maintenance.
We have a flood control district
and certainly this event has
overwhelmed that district but
but we've got some ideas and
some others DB G. --
Committee develop blocker and
other tools that --
They were hoping that we can use
and and leverage some of our
other resources with
[inaudible]
Next slide.
Issue six in the recovery
strategic plan was
infrastructure repair and
modifications.
And this is an area where we've
listed just a few projects here.
Most of the projects that we've
been working on a bridge
improvements in culverts and
drainages [inaudible]
Drainage facilities to improve
though to not only bill back
what was destroyed during the
one night event.
But also enhanced I'm so that
they can be more effective
should we get additional --
Debris flow and high intensity.
We've also done other has
delegation projects for Bella
Vista.
And at least those drive covert
replacements and it --
And with the goal to restore
those facilities to pre storm.
Edition. Seven focused on our
natural and cultural resource.
As you're aware and those you
thing of Ben and Montesinos or
live here for a long time --
Looks quite different in many of
the areas across mundus ito so
we've been in discussions on
engaging the community on
different kinds of ideas.
Potential projects to help
restore some of the patrol or
cultural resources --
Along the watersheds.
We've also been induced should
simply was Hannah Barbara land
trust.
Looking for opportunities to
collaborate together. To to
provide for some areas that duh.
Did help both of you a set back
from watercourses.
Or allow us to do additional --
Debris basin [inaudible]
Jim measures [inaudible]
Slide please.
This chapter focused on our
computer community engagement.
One of the I think things that
we were able to do. To work
collaboratively clap Lee with or
fuller foundation.
And a whole lot of nonprofits to
establish a mansio center.
That acted like a hub.
Still continues to operate as a
hub in the community.
Where folks can go in and --
Talk one on one with the person.
About the issues are the
questions that they have and
it's not just call in some
phone.
Number that connects with
somebody --
That they can't see and talk.
To this this monitor Skinner has
facilitated.
A lot of outreach to a lot of
impacted residents.
And we've also engage the
philanthropic sector --
And lot of nonprofits as you all
of our where have come together.
To really --
Address all of the community
needs.
We've also had a large showing
of the movie support Beto five
hope.
And the additional groups that
been focused on community
wellness across communities
[inaudible]
Slide.
As hopefully all of your where
we've had a communication --
Endeavor.
Across the entire --
Thomas fire one night briefs and
throughout recovery an array SPT
Dodd or well plight --
Has been up there were post all
of our newest information.
We take Jim --
Noble it or is that in a way
that it clear and easy to read.
And I've included newsletters
other things for folks out.
Slide please ongoing needs ten
you.
Have ongoing beads as we
continue to move through the
different phases of the
recovery.
Jean Ewing of the disaster
declaration [inaudible]
The level. To those future
events
[inaudible]
Looking
The group.
So next I'd like to introduce.
When look hope questioner?
I think it I think if we may
just take questions toward the
end because otherwise we're not
going to get through this --
Program and we want to hear from
everyone so say that program I
got a couple.
To and if we could ask you know
more than ten minutes so that we
are.
Out we didn't prepare dinner for
everybody so wanna get people
out here so they can go home but
Quinn anxious to hear what you
have to say so if.
Thank you senator Jackson --
Mona I I was thinking as you
were talking about the five
pounds you gain that I was
started to wonder about the
environmental impact of the
collective weight we've all
games and thinking that maybe we
need to put together like a
community --
Health program after we get
through the resiliency plan.
I'm [inaudible]
So.
I. in over the last few weeks
will bite most her young
schreiben watching with great
interest the rescuing of these
--
Boys in Thailand in this cave
and you know I think there's
some real parallels here there
were in murky waters and at
there's not enough ox been.
I and we need guidance --
To get is to a safer place and I
I just want to say that we're so
grateful. To have such
incredible leadership --
In the state --
Senator Jackson and and assembly
member at low Monning and in our
county Dawson and Mona and all
in the CIOS office we we really
--
I personally been so impressed
and so heartened by the coming
together of this community so.
Thank you so much for that I'm.
I was asked. To represent my
group which is the partnership
for resilient communities.
And let me just give you a
little background and how we
came together --
The core team of my group I is
--
Brett Matthews who is the former
actually president of the school
board money cedar union school
and is an entrepreneur and kind
of expert in public private
partnerships --
Joe Cole that chair of the
Planning Commission and the land
use lawyer in --
Munna Seto --
Pat McElroy former Santa Barbara
city fire chief.
Less Fierstein contractor
builder innovator happens to be
my husband but I would have
married again after I've seen
the kind of effort he's put into
this endeavor --
Mary Rose who is a public policy
consultant has been an amazing
partner in this I. leaks
Mattingly another local person
and really what happened is
after the debris flow.
We all came together and like so
many people we were looking for
our lane --
Of where to help and we went to
the county --
And basically said how can we
help you manage this.
Thing that none of us have have
ever seen before or we were all
in over our heads.
And we've basically said we want
to help you make our community
as safe as possible and put
together a plan so that we can
emerge.
Quote the six million dollar man
better stronger faster --
And really get through this as a
more resilient community and
not.
A double negative not not be
able to do things because NY.
One edge of government didn't
have the bad with of the money
to do it.
So that was really our goal was
just what can we do now to make
us more safe. To make them
mountain more safe and that's
really where this all began --
We started by engaging leaders
looking around because we all
know that.
As much as this was a new thing
for our community or not the
first community to experience.
The error --
Event that you know that how to
do with.
Wildland urban interface and and
so there were other people in
Switzerland in Washington state
in you know all over our country
in the world in Japan who have
gone through the sorts of things
and there are experts out there
including local experts at the
brand school all.
You know geologists in people
who have been thinking about
these things forever.
And who really at important
information to teach us about
technology that's out there and
things that we can --
Do now we engaged immediately
James Lee Witt who is the former
head of theme my and previously
worked with the local
partnership that built the
counties --
Aware and prepare pro --
And the emergency operations
center we hire.
Admiral Thad Allen --
From the coast are who had real
experience in dealing with --
These kinds of natural disasters
and we hired David through could
Tony who --
To work as a bridge between our
group and the county --
And David I. is the former
deputy director of cal O. yes
and former senior official FEMA
so he had some real expertise to
bring -- To
is issues as well --
And of course you know our most
important partners have been the
county in the state --
CDL Mona my Sato who has been
really from the very beginning
and I'm gonna need some of these
names then I'll quickly get.
To what we're actually doing but
the fact that these people who
are so overwhelmed.
Open up their arms. To a
partnership.
And really --
Welcome at the help and you know
joined arms without was so
impressive to us and heartening
and I I just can't tell you how
much we appreciate it --
Matt pond is who --
Was supposed to be less
interesting so that I would some
more interesting but that didn't
work out --
Senator Jackson --
Assemblywoman low moan --
Both of these leaders state
leaders and their from day one
were saying.
You know what do you think king
like out there open to why does
wanted to do everything they
could to support this community
and that's been amazing --
Supervisor Williams who has I
know lost so much sleep from the
day this happened you know
wanting to be there for this
community and wanting --
To you know.
Solve the problem that seemed
unsolvable so I you know that's
been incredible on the minds C.
to association Bob hazards
writing on this issue for the
modesty to journal has been so
helpful to all of us I'm super.
Superintendent rain I you have
opened the school in a way that
I know of so we are also
grateful --
For great support from theme of
all of this and so.
Really I'm.
Our partnership let me just tell
you sort of some of the things
that we're looking at that we've
been discussed with the county
and trying to do because really
we want to get some mitigation.
Up on the mountain.
For you know December before the
next rains because that's what
we're all concerned that we're
all concerned about.
You know temporary [inaudible]
Solutions before that natural re
growth can happen on the
mountain and some of the on
technologies that we're looking
at our monitors that can give us
real time data about.
Things that are happening up on
the mountain --
One of the technologies that
seem to be used around the
world.
Often and most effectively are
debris nets that --
I happen to be in.
Switzerland for a conference in
June and saw them all over the
mountains in Switzerland.
And that they they actually have
saved lots of property and lots
of lights around the world so
we're looking at doing temporary
netting --
That is environmentally bed that
has been as I said use all over
the world and hopefully the
first canyon will be able to put
Pat and as the Buena Vista
canyon because that canyon.
Does not have a debris basin at
the bottom of it so we're hoping
to be able to get this done and
again.
The county in the state has been
so I'm.
Working with that hand in hand
and try to do everything we
could to with they can to get.
Sort of emergency stays on you
know certain.
Approvals we would have to get
to do this --
In a more permanent way or if we
had eternal time to get it done
[inaudible]
I the other things we're looking
at is trying to help the county
--
Enhance the existing debris base
the network --
That we have to help accelerate
regrowth.
And ultimately what we all know
is that the entire problem is a
water problem.
And I know all of mine to see
those very focused on really
wanting to solve our all of
that.
State of California.
It certainly minus it was very
focused on how to solve this
problem --
And there are many things that
we're looking at doing a
facilitate better ongoing
hydration of the mountain --
Certainly if pot growers could
do it.
We can do it.
I I and a so that you know that
involves better water catchment
[inaudible]
Irrigation innovative ways to
get water on the mountain --
Like things like do harvesting
and atmospheric water and other.
Things that were just
considering because we sort of
feel like we are limited only by
the boundaries of our
imagination.
And our imaginations and into
the partnerships that were able.
To forum and yet one of the
groups that I didn't mention who
have been so incredibly --
Well we all know how amazing
that.
You no the firefighters and law
enforcement in Santa Barbara
county have been.
Unbelievable heroes in this
whole thing and have really
stepped outside of I think
everyone's stepped outside of
their comfort zone and of sort
of you know come to the table to
have the eager conversations
about how everything in pan.
Everything else and so we're so
grateful to have [inaudible]
Such amazing --
Leadership --
On that front [inaudible]
And I think I will.
Leave it there except to say
that -- You
know the habitat.
No you in terms of the state we
appreciate.
Not just everyone's talked about
the backfill and I know we're
sitting in the auditorium and
our school district appreciate
so much --
The backfill abut the economic
implications we know are going
to be more than a year.
So we're really hoping to find
longer term solutions --
As the mountain heels and our
economy.
He'll so thank you for the
opportunity to be here today and
we do have --
Serve a brochure or at the back
about what we're doing and we're
setting up a website
[inaudible] To sort of continue
to update with ongoing
technologies were looking at and
and where.
Endeavoring to pursue and we're
also doing this with the help of
some very generous people in
this community who have written
some.
Very generous chaps to find what
we're trying to do so that's
kind of the private piece of
this partnership is.
You know we're trying to pull
our personal wait in.
Getting us to higher ground
thank you.
Thank you thank you when.
And I. suspected people have
some good ideas that you are
going your folks are receptive
if somebody --
Has a suggestion that
[inaudible]
You might.
Interesting considering they
could they should come contact
you on that as well [inaudible]
I'm work.
Beyond being receptive we need
we have had I named the kind of
five or six core members of this
group but we have had so much
input from members of this
community.
The resources that we have more
than anything in this community
our human resources and it is
unbelievable the expertise and
that.
Creative and strategic thinking
is going on in this community
and the people who have come
together to sit with us and help
us think these things through
and I think I mentioned the
ministerial association is one
of the groups that's been.
So supportive of the work we're
doing and wanting to link arms
with us and so yes absolutely we
are.
Beyond open to input
[inaudible]
Chief.
Thank you are pretty being here.
If the invitation I've also
gained a lot of weight during
this whole thing [inaudible]
Any consolation.
Up I want to talk about.
Some things are working in our
favor during this whole endeavor
some challenges were having
moving forward we're gonna
continue to have some degree.
And a to do list --
I'll start with the things
working in our favor --
I've worked in this organization
I lived in pan on my whole life.
And I've never seen the fire
departments in this up very
again along the way.
Right now are are her
coordination communication with
each other --
The relationships we have with
Honestly has never been better
than it is right now and I think
some of that is because of the
personalities that are involved
a lot of it is because and the
challenges that we've all had to
face together the experiences
we've gained.
But that is a that's a any part
of it too is.
Pat McElroy here he was the old
city --
Citigroup recent retired C. fire
chief used to tend bar together
that might have some to do with
it -- But we
have a really good unified --
Group of fire chiefs and fire
departments here in this county
right now --
Public private partnerships its
partnership for the resulting
for resuming communities is is
really just an incredible
example and very unique to our
county --
The the the the public sector in
the private sector working
together and helping each other
out -- It's
a really encouraging sign when
you see things like that to
spring up out of nowhere.
And I find that to be extremely
encouraging --
Quick government solutions --
Let's face it government
typically is not particularly
nimble -- We
have really nice examples
recently of the government
acting quickly --
To make a real difference is on
in the field and on the ground
--
Senator Jackson's recent effort
and and assembly member low
moans recent effort --
To lobby the governor to add
additional monies for the pre
positioning.
Of fire and EMS resources in
front of predicted whether of
weather events --
Made a major impact on this
holiday fire that we recently
had just last weekend --
We're actually the first --
Agent we were the first fire
where these funds were utilized
--
In this unique fashion and we he
met the thresholds that were set
down by cal fire or or I should
also say that our relationship
with cal fire with our our
federal partners has never been
stronger also we have Tom Porter
from California with us --
We met the thresholds.
And we really prepa addition
five resources five five fire
engines a strike team
essentially who would not have
had otherwise --
Putting at the corner of
Hollister and turnpike and they
were.
There for two hours before the
holiday fire broke and they were
at work --
Read literally within minutes of
of of the fire starting so that
is an example of government
being nimble and making a real
--
Solid example so we've that I
think is extremely courage and
we have an engaged community
obviously --
This monster recovery center
that the county is putting out
there again I've been here for
thirty two years almost.
And I was here for the paint
fire it was here for he's see
that the I don't remember the
county being.
Leaning this far forward --
Connie recovery effort --
Ever before and you know part my
C. E. O..
Mona has given up after staff.
She's having to do a lot of met
partisans work --
Lately --
But I I I think those are very
encouraging things --
So those are good things other
challenges were having moving
forward.
At the most we have about months
to do fire prevention and any
kind of substantive fuel
management --
Because of this climate change
--
We literally just don't have the
time that we used to we used to
have sort of a semi well defined
fire season.
Stevo Safar marshals in the back
when we came on together when we
came on there was a fire season
and there was a non fire season.
And on fire season is when you
get all your training did all
your fire your your your fuel
management --
And we don't have that kind of
time anymore and and the I. it
my opinion the fire service
needs to adapt to that and we're
still in the in the process of
trying to do that --
I should also say that when I
speak I'm I'm I'm speaking for
all the fire certain not to
speaking as a county fire chief
we have to pick men here --
Kevin Taylor Travis is here from
the different from my seat of
fire department I I think they
all agree with the things that
I'm saying --
We have a difficult time getting
getting this work done because
on top of the fact that we're
always on fire it seems like --
The demand for mutual aid
resources out of our county --
Is extremely strong --
Because we ask for so much help
here locally we are duty bound
to provide health.
Provide Mitchell laid out a
county and in fact in this
holiday fuller broke we had a
strike team out of county and
and I think once you have some
people out also.
So it's really a year round
issue that we are still coming
to grips with and we have more
work to do --
We have less time to do
environmental review --
For fuel management projects --
There some misinformation out
there that --
That I think is proposes didn't
used to pose a big challenges it
as it does now but it poses a
bigger challenge now --
Manager burns if you'll breaks.
Our our tools that we need at as
fire departments and fire
fighters.
And when and there's
misinformation out there about
the efficiency of the
effectiveness of those tools --
Eight makes our job harder and I
find it personally affect
offense --
We would not have been able to
stop the Thomas fire --
Without the good work that might
aceto did providing the fuel
breaks in the thinning around
the back.
Of must feel that is what Scott
that fire in another field brick
running up to you to Roth road
--
We could not have put four
hundred fire trucks in a
thousand firefighters are.
More than more more firefighters
even then that appear to stop
this thing unfortunately we were
unable.
To save the watershed --
Convincing the public that when
we say that this is the new
normal we really mean --
I don't wanna sound gloom and
doom but when we say this is the
new normal what that really
means. To us as firefighters is
this is not a hope we're gonna
get over this [inaudible]
Is [inaudible]
Is.
This is reality now we're not
gonna get over this it's not
going to get better and so as a
community and as a fire service
we need to adapt to that.
That's a challenge --
Very difficult to coordinate
local state and federal land
owners --
Ranchers farmers the
environmental community elected
officials --
In time to do subsidy fuel
management projects really
really difficult it was
difficult in the old days before
it got like it is now --
And it's even more difficult now
and that's what my whole
Mitchell but later here.
Learning from history I I I
think that we really especially
here in Santa Barbara county.
We need to learn from history --
In nineteen ninety I was I was
here three years as a
firefighter.
And we had the predicate fire
and very similar conditions that
we had at the holiday fire --
What we keep learning is that
these fires --
They like to start up in the
mountains they like to run down
in the populated areas --
Take homes and kill people they
run back up in the hills at
night in their run back down the
next day it happened during the
T. fire happened during his C.
to fire.
But what is happening now and I
think what we really need to be
aware of unconscious above is.
Interval between those events
used to be five to ten years --
Now if we get whether.
Generally speaking we're gonna
get a fire --
The interval between those large
catastrophic events is
increasing.
And we need to adapt to that we
need to take substantive action.
So are here's my here's my to do
list.
In my opinion we need a
countywide I don't know if this
is the correct terminology or
what we're even gonna call this
thing but I believe that we need
a countywide fuel management
working group.
Comprised of all those people
that all those members of
organizations that I just
mentioned that need to be
coordinated nor to get any work
done -- We
need to get those people the
environmental community.
Elected officials state federal.
And local fire agencies.
And we need to get planned
together with the priority being
we need a front country feel
break in this in this town we
need test [inaudible] To put.
Some form of a fuel break that
runs from the good work that
mocks you already did.
Alway out to behind the leader
--
It can take the form of actual
manage actual fuels removed
either through hand crews goats
a canticle means --
Or can take the that form of
agriculture --
You know I I think there are
friends of ours the agriculture
community would.
You say that but avocados and ag
belts.
I act as big hit he and they
they take up a lot of members
you know when we had the sure
fire -- The
avocado orchards out there when
a long way toward saving Toledo
from from from catastrophic
[inaudible]
A loss.
So we need to have we need to
connect the dots in the front
country or we are just going to
be in my opinion.
Fits with this problem over and
over again it's a heavy lift --
There's a lot of assets there's
a lot of there's a lot of apple
carts that.
That a will be upset in the
process but I think until we do
something are on that scale.
We are going to continue C.
these problems and finally I
have to throw this in there we
need to unify our dispatch
services in this county --
Right now in this county we have
five dispatch centers.
It's not unified we respond on
most of the time different
frequencies it creates problems
for us on small scale bird to
seize and particularly in large
scale emergencies --
During the debris flow during
the Thomas fire.
We had difficulties because we
were not responding on the same
frequency oftentimes we what are
our mobile data computers are
fire trucks once in the scene
[inaudible]
Thing.
So situational awareness that
responding resources had going
in these large incidents was not
as good as it could have been
and it's a problem.
We are far too forward thinking.
Of accounting and of a community
to have an unified dispatching
environment is something we
absolute need to fix I'm working
my C. Yom --
Monning Misato dust Williams
just left there where the
problem we're looking at active
--
Solutions met Pontus is part of
the part of the team --
But that's a big one on the to
do list facing these major
catastrophes as we move forward.
Thank you thank you chief we've
written it down both of us so
thank you.
And so people aren't to
discourage we are actually
moving on those --
Levels and we'll talk about that
a little later thank you and now
--
Katie dedicate which you share
with us what's going on if you
could keep it under ten minutes
at a great camp.
I I'm Kate we be I am the
director of the institute for
collective trauma and growth.
And we have been --
Working for years now and asters
and long term I. recovery
efforts around the country and
we happen to be based here and
so were immediately responsive
and and created a local project
that we're calling the revere
care center and we set up
offices in the monocyte of
Skinner.
And I also serve as the long
term recovery I. group chair.
And so in that role I've been
working very closely with Ben
Romano and other county
representatives and especially
as we've seen how --
Helpful and successful the
Montesinos center has been --
This collaborative effort has
really --
And and the hub that Matt talked
about has really helped to
create kind of a one stop shop
that people could go to for the
wide range of it's that --
Are part of the long term
recovery effort.
And so that this collaboration
is not going to end anytime soon
and we'll be together at least
through --
The next evacuation season so at
least through March and we have
started conversations --
About the possibility of
remaining in the same location
--
As we are right now and so if
that changes at all we will for
sure update the public --
As soon as possible --
And right now some of that the
reason that we are forecasting
that way is because while the
modesty of center was effective
immediately --
Everyone processes trauma and
goes through their own --
Sense of disaster at their pace
and so while many people --
Sought out resources right away
they're people who are just
starting to come to seek out
services right now.
They're just starting to realize
--
That maybe they weren't --
As insured as they thought they
were or or their rebuilding
efforts are costing.
They're just starting to feel
some of the impacts of the
motion on and spiritual and
psychological impacts --
They're just starting --
To recognize some of the longer
term impacts on their businesses
and so -- We
have services at Montesinos
honor to address that wide range
of needs [inaudible]
Great.
Thank you very much --
And again will have questions at
the end if we could call up our
second panel now thank you folks
you really have.
Done an amazing job let's.
Give a round of applause.
So our next panel is Tom Eric
Allama row with the yum.
Cal away assets C. office of
emergency services who have
been.
Sort of helping to coordinate
these efforts from the state
level --
Providing money and resources
and leadership.
And then I'm gonna passes back
to my colleague to identify the
next members.
We also have a a chief Tom
Porter who is here adjoining us
from the southern region --
He's a southern region chief for
cal fire who we've worked very
closely with.
As well as Dave Edwards from and
he's bureau chief of the claim
service bureau in the consumer
service division for
California's department of
insurance.
This panel and is again focus on
some the efforts that the state
has engaged in in response --
It to that natural disasters and
the post natural disaster
situations so we will start I'm
with Eric lateral --
I do want to note that and we do
have some who's keeping time in
case you need any suggestions of
sitting here in the front row.
And the and will flag just I'm
kind of the minute warnings for
S. and to please had.
Thank you very much summit
member senator for having us
here today --
I'm gonna --
And build upon moments of RD
been made --
There's some areas have been
touched on wear a through the
legislative action and the
governor's action we got funding
to support --
Our programs ahead of the Vance.
Sorry about that that better
yeah.
I want to reinforce some of the
points have been made --
In terms of how the some of the
funding that's been have
provided by the legislature and
the governor to support --
Resource deployments ahead of
them it's as well as to look at
hazard mitigation --
We've certainly at the
governor's office of emergency
services.
Learned a tremendous amount --
Through the events of twenty
seventeen obviously here first
and foremost of the Thomas fire
in the one nine debris flow.
But unfortunately across
California twenty seventeen was
a really catastrophic year from.
The significant flooding events
we had throughout California at
the beginning the year.
Our crisis at the Oroville lake
Oroville facility.
And then bookending with the
events.
I'm from October through
December unfortunately
throughout California we lost
eleven thousand homes and
businesses.
Throughout all these events on
M. is senator Jackson
highlighted earlier tremendous
--
And unacceptable loss of life
across those events --
Locally we have continued to
remain engaged --
Here in Santa Barbara and
Ventura counties and throughout
this region in supporting the
significant debris removal
operations --
Here in Santa Barbara county --
Overseeing the U. S. army corps
of engineers programs to to
clear our channels on our basins
--
Downturns Jr accounting.
Leading up the debris from seven
hundred homes that were lost
during the Tom spire.
No what we've realizes there's
tremendous success based on the
partnerships of local state and
federal partners and the
leadership.
Of local officials both during
response and into recovery here
in Santa Barbara.
Has been a tremendous I'm our
team has been engaged on both
the disaster response and
recovery --
Here at that San Santa Barbara
EOC and in working with Matt his
recovery team and will continue
--
To and as we've --
Worked to ensure that there's an
expeditious flow of federal and
state dollars for those recovery
efforts.
You were working on what can we
do better to be --
Better prepared for that next to
that --
Through the will the leadership
of the governor and director Gil
duty --
Earlier this year after the
catastrophic debris flow when we
saw additional events coming in
additional weather events --
We actually did something we've
never done before we pre
positioned recovery resources --
We mobilize a state agency
experts from the department of
water resources and Caltrans and
other agencies.
As well as we pass the federal
government with mobilizing the
US army corps of engineer
contractors in the event that we
had another event like the one
nine flow.
So that we could expeditiously
get in there and clean up debris
and get the community back on
its feet fortunately.
Those storms did manifest the
way we thought they were going
to but we were per aired for
that --
Additionally --
As we saw most recently.
With the fires last week.
I'm we had the ability --
Through additional funding in
legislation that have been
authorized to pre position
critical resources to support
Santa Barbara county --
As was noted we had. Twenty five
million dollars in funding
statewide --
We have the ability now to pre
positioning coordination with
cal fire and local partners
[inaudible]
Critical resource.
Critical --
Firefighting response resources
as well as other M. Nancy
management resources --
To be prepared when we've got
events that meet the critical --
Whether in other threshold
factors that are considered we
had five of Callaway esses
engines here Hannah Barbara as
noted.
Those engines were [inaudible]
Holiday fire [inaudible]
Time we had six local
governments [inaudible]
Directing.
Positioned in Los Angeles some
of those engines and it up
getting deployed.
An additional response up here
in in because of the the funding
that was available in the
program that's in place we're
able to back fill those in the
event that it [inaudible]
Significant fire a broken in Los
Angeles during that time --
We were also fortunate during
the holiday fire to the federal
fire management assistance grant
--
It's probably the fastest
approval I've ever seen --
For a FEMA fire management
assist [inaudible]
And all [inaudible]
Very fortunate [inaudible]
Federal government [inaudible]
On while we've been working
[inaudible]
Fireside [inaudible]
Need.
Ahead of the Vance.
We all can in your work.
Developing standards at the
state level.
I know there's legislation
[inaudible]
Centered we're trying to be
ahead of that by developing
standards [inaudible]
That can.
Coincide with whatever
legislation gets passed --
We've formed a committee --
That's developed on a draft
recommendations on that are
currently under review that that
will establish a standard.
Eighteen a base level for all
alert warning throughout
California --
That we can --
Uses a model especially help
jurisdictions that aren't as
robust in terms of alert warning
and Santa Barbara and Ventura
are.
So lot of lessons are being
learned and best practices being
you realize that we've been
seeing down here.
The final --
Areas all touch on that Matt
touched on earlier --
Is the state hazard mitigation
grant funding --
There's a program after every
major a presidential disaster
where 20% of the overall cost of
that disaster.
Gets applied to additional
funding that's allocated to the
state. To provide funding grants
to local governments to take
steps to mitigate future losses
future disasters.
Although --
This funding is driven by fires
--
The grants themselves apply for
flood mitigation for fire
mitigation for earthquake
[inaudible]
Across California.
Through the October disasters
and December does a disaster if
three and seventy one million
dollars here in Santa Barbara
county.
There been --
Fifty nine Wilk what's called
notice of interests that have
been submitted to us we've
approved fifty of those in the
counties now working.
On many of those to submit
applications to us and so will
continue to provide subject
matter expertise to them as they
work through that grant
development process and look
forward.
To as some of those actions
being implemented from flood
mitigation measures that that.
That Matt touched on to fire
clearance --
Efforts on another flood control
measures that will greatly
enhance --
The ability to reduce low.
So I think you very much for
allowing us to be here today.
Think.
And upfront thank you.
I thought senator Jackson and
assembly a member of the Monning
for having us here --
I think this could be the the
panel of we're from the state
we're here to help --
And Hannah I I I I see that with
a little bit of a joke in my
voice --
Only because we that truly is
what were best --
Here to do is help your local --
Government officials and your
local --
Departments --
To recover from what you've been
through --
And I I I don't think it's lost
on any of you that that the
frequency is --
Has increased --
Dramatically --
Here in the front country of
Santa Barbara county it's
increased in your back country
as well --
You've had more fires in the
last -- Five
years -- On
average then --
In the period that long.
Or that of of that length --
In the past so --
Santa Barbara's not unlike the
rest of the state --
As senator Jackson Jackson
mentioned --
The climate change is changing
the fire environment and in
general --
It can be said no matter where
you are in California --
Every acre can and will burn at
some point.
And we're just seeing more
frequent and larger --
Displays of that --
As we are so with that --
Where are we with --
The new normal --
The new normal is the normal --
And so we're we are.
Changing that vernacular within
our our department --
Because new normal that was good
two years ago --
This year in going for work
we're at a point where this is
the normal.
And the state --
Has through through much of the
effort of of your officials
appear on the stage but also on
the backs of of you when the
local --
Elected officials.
Had have made a Andy
astronomical investment in the
future of of the fire services
--
In general in California
[inaudible]
Or is.
Working hard to meet the the
expectations of the funding that
has been.
Pushed in our direction --
Through --
Increasing our the readiness of
our fleet --
We've increased some numbers of
firefighting --
Capable resources both human and
and equipment --
We're increasing our our
commitment to our environmental
planner types who will be
helping with our in secret
clearance --
For fuels reduction work and
prescribed fire.
And let me just give you some of
the the the numbers --
Seeking --
Reference these going forward
and you couldn't you can pull
these out of the the governor's
executive order --
For force management --
But also --
Some of the that numbers of of
dollars that have are coming out
of of the current budget --
Sixteen million dollars will --
Worth of a replacement for
equipment --
Vehicles that we've been sorely
needing M. and behind on
replacement umps will be up
upgrading our our fleet --
A ten million dollars in
community based fire prevention
work that's going to be coming
directly down to the ground
level and for our communities to
draw on through their local --
County fire and or cal fire
units -- To
to work on local based again
this is for us to help you help
yourselves to become more
resilient --
In protection of your
communities --
From wildfire in their disasters
--
There are going to be --
Six fire --
Fuels management crews that the
state is is --
Going to hire and have as a
permanent --
Piece of our our arsenal and
they're knocking me fire going
crews they're gonna trained to
fire going standards and they
will react if there's a fire
locally.
But their whole mission for
those six cruise is going to be
fuels work.
So that's something that we're
gonna be doing throughout the
state and where there's a
critical need --
We will move those crews into
those areas and do those
projects and then --
Respond accordingly and and
retract accordingly.
We got the fires.
There last year's budget had two
hundred million dollars worth of
of fuels management --
Dollars that has right now --
Almost all been allocated to
large scale projects across
California --
We a have been --
Getting a grant money for fuels
project work and the hundreds of
thousands to several million
dollars --
Per year and targeting those --
Two places where they would have
been needed.
These are going in large chunks
to large landscape level
projects to do watershed level
work.
And so --
Some some of those funds will be
coming -- To
the local area.
We'll be touching every --
Every part of California.
This year an additional hundred
and sixty million dollars to is
going into the same program so.
Between last year and this year
three hundred sixty plus million
dollars are going to fuels --
Related work --
To help --
Towards.
Mitigating the forced up issues
but also the the fuels issues
around communities.
The other part of the executive
order --
Point toward increasing the pace
and scale of of work on the
landscape --
To reduce fuels.
Are we are currently doing an
average of approximately two
hundred and fifty thousand acres
of of project work across the
state.
We will --
Be increasing that to
approximately a half million
acres -- If
you look at that as a whole --
It's it's not enough on the on
the entire statewide basis but
the federal got black. For
service and federal agencies are
committing to an additional half
million acres of one million --
Per year that we are looking at
moving toward --
Over the next several years.
The we're gonna be doing more
our education and outreach and
certifying more individuals and
departments in prescribed.
We're gonna be looking at the
liability issue of that and
fearing out ways that we can
work toward shared liability --
In some fashion under a
controlled setting.
And streamlining the permitting
process to get from.
A planned burn or project.
To the work being done on
around.
There the governor --
Enacted a tree mortality taps
force I'm sorry tree mortality
task force that was last year
last three years.
That has morphed into the forest
management task force force
management task force is going
to be working with all --
All of the state agencies and
our federal counterparts. To do
all of these things that I
mentioned previously.
But to to collaborative Lee --
Come to a point where world
we're speaking with one voice --
In moving toward --
More resilient Morrell zillion
forests and more resilient.
And Evert me say Forrest several
times.
Forest is what we have behind
you -- If
you think of forest like the
Forest Service because their
poorest.
And we have a lot of acres of
forest that are in southern
California that have no trees on
but that is still is Boris so --
When I'm to it when I'm saying
these and and --
Working through some of the
issues that that we are going to
be working through over the next
several years and possibly
decades --
Think of the forest as
everything that's out your
backdoor.
And know that we only control
and and I have the the ability
to work on those private lands
there between us and the federal
government.
But also know that the federal
lands managers are committed to
working with us to move forward
on on the things that we need to
to have.
Resilient forests watersheds and
communities [inaudible]
Thank.
Skinner Jackson is them we
member limo and thank you for
the opportunity for us to be
here tonight putting this
together.
My name is Dave Edwards I'm the
chief of the clan services
bureau of the department of
insurance my team is responsible
for assisting survivors with
their parents claims on the
speeds.
Richards commissioner Dave Jones
who was able to visit Santa
Barbara county a number of times
earlier this year and wanted me
to convey his continued
commitment. To using all the
powers of his office. To assist
survivors.
First I'd like to provide the
community in the committee with
updated insured loss claims data
from the two thousand seventeen
wild fires as well as the two
thousand eighteen Montecito
mudslides.
From October December two
thousand seventeen wildfires in
northern and southern California
more than fifty three thousand
claims have been filed. Seventy
two hundred of these have been
total loss claims.
As of our most recent data the
total insured losses now exceed
twelve point five billion
dollars.
From the December two thousand
seventeen Thomas fire alone that
impacted Santa Barbara and
Ventura counties more than nine
thousand four hundred claims
have been filed and more than
seven hundred of those were
total loss claims.
The Tom aspire is now
approaching two billion dollars
an insured losses.
As you know the mind of C. to
mudslides cause significant
property damage and tragic loss
of life.
More than twenty eight hundred
claims been filed with more than
a hundred fifty of these being
total loss claims.
And the total insured losses
from the mud slide now exceeds
six hundred fifty million
dollars.
Now this date is from homeowners
commercial and auto insurers in
the private market.
It does not include any claims
have been filed under the flood
program.
Now Mike provided a brief
summary of what commissioner
Jones in the department have
been doing since the onset of
these terrible events.
In the northern and southern
California fires commissioner
Jones in the department took a
number of immediate steps to
help affected residents and
communities --
He signed orders to cut through
the red tape allowing insurance
companies to move more quickly
to provide advance payments tell
presidents get the resources
they need. To start the recovery
in rebuilding process.
We mobilized our disaster
response teams were provide
service to wildfires survivors.
We issued notices to make sure
that insurance professionals
including.
Professional a public adjusters
insurers and claims adjusters.
We're reminded of their
obligations to know and follow
all laws pertaining the claim
settlement.
Including the California unfair
practices act.
The fair claim settlement
practice rags and additional
consumer protections that
supersedes standard policy
language when there's a declared
disaster.
Such as was the case with these
fires and the muscle.
In addition our consumer
services team was deployed to
local assistance centers
providing a one on one support
for thousands of fire survivors.
Our investigators detectives
were from our enforcement branch
teamed up.
With the contractors state
license board and local district
attorneys to attend cat town
hall meetings.
Visit affected neighborhoods and
educate residents on how to
avoid scam artists.
Pray on disaster victims after
the disaster occurs.
Commissioner Jones issued a
notice to insurance carriers
asking them to waive the
requirement of a detailed home
inventory. For policy holders
and pay up to a 100% of the
contents coverage.
So that fired --
Survivors who experienced a
total loss could be spared the
painful task of trying to
remember in list every item they
owned.
The insurers that agreed to
comply with our request made up
more than 98%.
The the total loss clings fired
filed as a result of the two
thousand seventeen wildfires.
Regarding the January mudslides
commissioner Jones toured the
impact --
Locations we deployed our
disaster response teams to the
areas to assist people at the
local acceptance centers we also
held town hall meetings and
workshops to assist as many
survivors as possible.
In January of this year.
After hearing that some
insurance companies were
advising their insurance that
mud slide damage was not covered
under the homeowner policy.
Commissioner Jones issued
unnoticed all property insurers
this notice reminded insurers of
the efficient proximate cause
doctrine which is California
law.
Their duty was to cover damages
from the recent mudslides and
debris flows if it was
determined.
The Tom aspire was the efficient
proximate cause of the mud
slides.
The preliminary and subsequent
information showed that the
Thomas fire which was a covered
peril.
What the official proximate
cause of the subsequent mud flow
mudslides and debris flows?
Therefore we do expect insurers
to cover these claims under the
property owners homeowner's
insurance policy.
As well as under commercial
policies in most cases
[inaudible]
We understand.
The for those whose homes are
covered under the national flood
insurance program their claims
may be completely or partially
covered under those policies as
well.
The department held several one
on one workshops allowed
survivors the opportunity to
speak with department claims
experts in a private session.
On the central coast those
workshops were held in February
both inventor and Senate Barbara
and again in April in.
Santa Barbara.
We met with hundreds of
survivors during those
workshops.
In all commissioner just ones
are and my staff met with more
than five thousand survivor
statewide in these various
venues.
After meeting with fires
survivors across the state and
having heard first and the
challenges they were facing.
Commissioner Jones directed the
department of insurance to
develop a package of proposed
statutory changes to strengthen
the law in this area.
The department sponsored and
drafted several bills.
That would assist current and
future survivors of wildfires
and other disasters with their
recovery.
Several of several of these
bills are still active and it is
our hope they will be enacted in
its strong the form as possible.
Some statistics today the
department received four hundred
sixty two consumer requests for
assistance or complaints.
Relating to the October December
wildfires.
Many of these cases are under
investigation still but so far
through our intervention we have
been able to recover more than
forty million dollars for
survivors. For the Tom aspire
the department received eighty
four consumer requests for
assistance and so far we've been
able to recover four million
dollars the Thomas wildfire
survivors. For the money Seto
went mudslides the department
has not received a large number
of complaints.
Especially after commissioner
Jones issued his January notice.
Advising Richard the efficient
proximate cause doctrine we
received about twenty
complaints.
I would like to say that if any
member of the public.
Has suffered a loss from the mud
slides please file your claim
with your insurance company.
If that claim is denied or even
delayed please contact the
department and filed a request
for assistance.
Now last week the department
receipt to specific questions
from committee staff I would
like to address those questions.
The first question involves
insureds to do not feel that
their insurers providing
adequate compensation for their
claim we were asked.
What would your office suggest
they do next to rebut the
insurance companies offer?
Are there resources that either
your office or another entity
can offer to guide individuals
through this process.
In the case were insured is at
an impasse with their insurer in
feels they're not they're not
being fairly compensated.
We would ask that you
immediately contact the
department's we sign the case to
an insurance compliance officer
who can seek to resolve the
dispute.
Our department staff have the
expertise to resolve many of
these disputes and if there's
issue that we cannot.
Have that cannot be resolved
through our wrecked intervention
the department administers a
statutory disaster mediation
program.
Under that program survivor may
wish to enter into mediation
where we assign an outside
mediator to seek resolution of
the claim dispute issue.
This mediation program is free
for a consumer.
It is non binding.
So if the consumers not happy
with the suggested supplement
the consumer may walk away and
pursue other remedies.
At the conclusion of this
hearing a member of my team will
be in the back of the auditorium
with brochures that describe the
mediation program.
The second question we were
asked.
In isn't imply that some
insurers are the lane mud slide
damage claims.
In order to wait for a report or
updated FEMA maps.
The question also suggested that
updated FEMA maps may be used an
impact future insurance rates in
premium.
In the area of the months like.
The department is not aware of
any insurer that is waiting on a
theme of report or updated map
to invent or in order to
investigate evaluate were
settled either wildfire or much
like claim.
We have received no complaints
that any insurers Dillane
settlement of claims waiting for
report or updated map.
If their is a constituent that
is experiencing to delay by
their insurer on the this basis
they should immediately contact
us.
The question also refers of the
possible readjustment insurance
rates.
Insurance rates are regulated by
the department under very strict
standards uninsured may not
automatically raise rates and
therefore individual insurance
the insurance premiums.
Without first meeting a new rate
filing with the department's
rate regulation branch.
That filing must then be
approved by the department.
Therefore we do not expect there
to be any immediate rate premium
impact as a result of new
reports or mapping of the
modesty to area.
However the department will
obtain a review any reports or
maps that are prepared.
Lastly for a type of insurance
issue or dispute if any member
of the public is having
difficulty with.
Or just not sure about the
advice being given by nature an
adjuster an agent or broker.
Please contact our consumer
services team toll free at
1-800-927-4357.
Or you can visit us online at
insurance dot CA dot gov.
Now we can't resolve all the
issues of disputes that are
brought to our attention but we
certainly cannot help.
If we're not contacted.
This concludes my testimony for
any of those would like the
department to review their case.
An officer of my team is in the
back of the room afterwards to
provide our requests for
assistance forms.
Thank you.
Well thank you.
Thank you this is been helpful
other senator and I are going to
give a brief legislative update
in terms of what each of us --
And what the state has been
working on and then following
that we will open it up for
public comments I hope the
evolving taking notes and
keeping your questions together.
Us Sacramento has been
particularly busy --
In response to the natural fires
up the senator and I have not
only met with our colleagues
that represent some of the most
impacted and I. areas in
northern California.
I'm on a periodic basis to
discuss I'm a collective effort
in terms of moving forward but
there have been many members on
in the legislature who have
proposed a series of bills.
That we have a list --
And for those of you who may
want to you can you can get at
the back of the room are and in
the front of the the hall.
I'm with over forty bills that
were introduced in.
This legislative year.
That relate to natural disaster
response and recovery I think
that some of our panelists M. in
this last panel have alluded to
bills are still alive some of
those bills.
I'm are no longer in place.
And a few of those bills have
been introduced by the both of
us and we have been working
together on on the bills that
we're moving forward one of the
bills that M. that.
I co that I authored it have the
senator is a co author is.
An office of emergency service
translation bill we know and we
heard loud and clear as did
northern California --
How important it was to get
timely and for the state in a
state that represents over 44%
of individuals who speak a
language other than English in
their home?
On and that is something that we
are working on unfortunately
bill that we that we did start
to work on the but that did not
make it M. all the way was the
consolidated removal program.
What you have all experienced in
terms of the services with a
consolidated debris removal is
something that is not law it
eight tends to happen?
On because we work on it to make
it happen M. but that is not a
law and we are working and I
will look likely revisit it in
the coming years and that that
is a bill that died --
Bills die in a number of six to
eight different process and they
can die in different ways and it
so that was one of them.
Out we did have actually.
Add that to the cal fire chief
mentioned one of the bills and
that we authored which is the
fire prevention activities local
assistant grant program.
And as a over ten million
dollars to create.
A new fire prevention working
group composed of
representatives and stakeholders
from state agencies local
governments I. academia
interests industry and
nonprofits that have experience.
An arm vault in state fire
prevention at the schools a
working group up with the grant
program at to identify what
those methods are.
At those are some of them I know
that we additionally have some
budget --
Work that we've we've.
Been able to successfully get to
work group and the state I'm
representatives on that some of
those -- Fun
to include --
Backfill for property taxes for
both Ventura and Santa Barbara
county add backs bill for
attendance related loss and
school districts --
And that's specific to K. twelve
and community college at school
districts we do have a as well
as and some.
Some match money for a the
Associated add debris removal
for both Fincher and Santa
Barbara county as well.
And so those are some of the
efforts I think add that we've
engaged in everything we've done
as a center has said we've done
together not just on because we
represent the disk.
But we've also done it with
colleagues on in northern
California and colleagues in the
state legislature [inaudible]
As well.
I and I I would say that it's
this whole circumstance with the
Thomas farmer summer prescient
--
Yeah I have I chair the joint
committee on emergency
management --
And have been very actively
involved in this issue since I
was elected to the Senate I
chaired it for the first session
which is two years.
As a vice chair last year and
the chair this year and it so
happened that.
On December fourth.
I was chairing a committee
meeting on the early alert
systems --
Having gone out to northern
California and had my first
helicopter experience one of
those really clunky old National
Guard helicopters it ended up
causing me.
To have problems with my I. neck
if you've never written in a
helicopter you're not missing
anything.
I especially.
Especially I think Vietnam War
era.
That type of helicopters should
any rate.
Riding in a helicopter and
seeing an area called coffee
park I don't know if you've all
seen that the photo of this
place on in Santa Rosa.
This is a community of the
several flower totally
destroyed.
By that fire up in Santa Rosa
where -- We
lost about Decatur nine thousand
homes and about forty three
lives forty four large.
And so it was clear that we had
a problem with our emergency
alert systems they they were not
working of this fire came very
quickly it all sounds familiar
because it is familiar.
And so I was finishing up a
hearing.
On December fourth on these
emergency alert system sent a
talking about the fact we really
needed to shore this whole
process apart nine eleven
system.
Forty years old I mean basically
before the internet --
Are universal alert systems well
they go too far and not CPAS
enough and many of you during
the Thomas fire probably got
that o'clock in the morning.
Alert telling us to evacuate
except what they're really
trying to still people
Carpinteria to evacuate.
So our systems clearly --
Needed work so I bang the gavel
down a five o'clock and said
sort of bows fully well it's
December hopefully our fire
season is.
Is pretty well behind us it'll
give us a few months to really
try to come to grips with this
and and get moving to try to
correct going forward.
An hour and a half later
[inaudible]
Thomas Firestar.
In December actually unheard off
that we would have a fire that
magnitude in December that
burned for forty days and we all
experience with that that
created so.
I have done a bill.
That authorizes its SP eight
twenty one it's an emergency
notification bill.
What we discovered and it's the
same problem we're still having
today in our community people do
not sign up?
Now granted we had some problems
bingo Lita people did sign up
and didn't get noticed will deal
with that problem.
A believing we will deal with
that problem.
The fact is people aren't
signing up well you know you
going Google in you get signed
up for all sorts of stuff that
you don't want to be signed up.
For so how about a system where
the county candidates
discretion.
Sign people up to get these
emergency alerts by using
information based upon your
utility bills we know where
people live and we know even if
their phone numbers are
reflective of a NATO five area.
So that people will get notice
and if they don't want to be
part of it they can opt out.
But it is an opt in system and
dumb a I do believe that we have
a lot of support on that from
our public safety people you
know the job to alert people is.
Of the job of law enforcement
and I do know that almost all
our law enforcement in
California supports that.
I'm it was mentioned the debris
flow the X. India efficient
proximate cause issue.
That is a Lara California but
it's in it's not actually in
statute it's the case law that
has come down so basically.
There is absolutely no doubt
that Thomas fire was the cause
of the debris flow.
And I don't know that they're
any insurance companies at this
point Tom that are denying that
but they're sort of hanging back
a little bit from what I gather
in when I was here.
In January you gave me a list of
those companies that were
problem and they're still marked
in big bold letters and reading
could my notebook and I I'm
going after those.
Companies to pay up but this is
such a bill I'm doing SP nine
seventeen Skinner actually put
this into statute.
So that there's no way these
companies can get around I'll
tell you it's very interesting
they're trying very hard
undermining.
My ability to get this bill
passed --
But I am determined and then not
the last item I wanted to
mention was a bill SP twelve
sixty the fire prevention and
protection.
Which I authored again in part
because of the experience that
we've had throughout the state
in the fact that.
It what they didn't mention is
that currently California now
has. Hundred and thirty eight
billion dead trees.
Which are about as flammable is
anything you can imagine that in
there not all up in the forest
and moving California.
And that its almost impossible
to try to cut down all these
trees but what we can do in one
of the things that this bill
doesn't a cheap Peterson mention
it serve obliquely but we don't
we haven't been doing any burns
we have been doing.
Any kind of controlled burns in
the state because for a lot of
good reasons but you know what.
We gotta start doing these
controlled burns and we're gonna
do them as protectively as
possible we've brought this bill
includes your quality control
districts. To to be part of this
discussion but if you inhaled
those fumes for forty days as
many of us did this is not
healthy.
And we need to do better to
manage our forests and that's
what SP twelve sixty does using
the experts you you saw some of
them here with no yes you saw
them locally --
Dealing with the fact that we
have a wildlife urban interface
we called the Wu we which is
job.
Different than the forests up in
northern.
It's a very different chaparral
is different I and what we're
doing is bringing together these
experts to figure out a plan to
try to thin the forests. To thin
the area so that we don't end
up.
Standing there watching
helplessly and with great trauma
as that fire moved from Santa
Paula.
All the way to the back country
in in Montecito in Santa Barbara
we've got to do better that is
part of that is the of the curse
of the climate change that we're
experiencing this those droughts
the bark beetles to things that
are destroying.
Our forest destroying our
chaparral and we've got to
address that problem so that's
SP twelve sixty the governor put
a hundred and sixty million
dollars into the budget this
year for this long term forest
health and wildlife a wildfire.
Resiliency including of money
for it we estimate about hundred
twenty million will go for this
so.
The state is putting money in --
We have are working
collaboratively and I think --
Yes under values.
The county.
Has never really experienced
anything like this before but oh
yes house the office of
emergency services state so
coming together working in the
emergency management program
with a with Roth.
I in in the others who have
dealt with some fires and we we
are somewhat experienced in them
here in California and it in
locally but this was an event
that.
Was so complex.
That it did that market would do
choose the head of the office of
emergency services who was a
rock star --
It set at had worked with the
Jamie Lee I. what's his name
Jamie.
Jamie Lee Witt who was a double
also rockstar --
It's it in all the years of
twenty five years that.
He's been working on fires he
said this is the most complex.
A event he's ever experienced so
bringing together this
collaborative effort with the
state with the feds FEMA was
there for us --
We got a huge amount of money a
again money is critical because
if we have to take money for
these fires that we could and
should be using for a variety of
services within this community.
Up we are.
Going to really be --
Unduly strapped interest.
In never able to dig out of this
whole I'm gonna.
Let my colleague here --
Take over from here where I
think we do have questions I'm I
just wanna give a shout out to
the staff that your we've got
some sergeants here from
documento.
I'm gonna give a particular
thanks to Fernando Ramirez who
is my staff a native of Santa
pollen.
Who's a works for me in the
capital and help put this all
together.
I know Monique staff has been.
Working very hard in this.
All of you for being here thank
you thank you we will get
through this it's going to be
tough.
But heck we're Senate Barbour
county we can do anything.
And likewise I want to give
thanks Jimmy red rock I have any
Lopez Stephanie I mean it's not
that they amount of the us you
know several folks who are here
who have been working.
On when the center and I are in
Sacramento which on a regular
basis every single week we do
have team members who are here
--
Who are the voice in the ears
and that way we cannot be here
so it thinks everyone what we'd
like to do is we have set up a
microphone?
I'm here at the front I'm for
public comment again this was
the opportunity for us to bring
a taste of what our Sacramento
hearings are like to the local
community so this is your
opportunity. To get a public
comment into display of record
it can also be a question if we
have the capacity to answer a
question we may or may not.
Have the capacity to answer
questions and we can try to
answer those questions but again
this is the opportunity for you
at to get anything you'd like
into the legislative record.
And please state your name --
First [inaudible]
Thank you.
My name's Toni spayed or Adams
time here run to representing
two different groups one so
twenty three homeowners on
Montecito Vista off Parker pass
road.
Our first question is.
They are related to that county
and how.
And to get our first responders
to live in that community
because there's fear with the
road closure so many of our
first responders live outside of
the area.
Our second concern is that we
attended M. wanna see a Planning
Commission a board of
supervisors hearing.
Joe Cole who's here with us
today and chief Heckman we heard
their professional consultants
report about back burning house
for senator Jackson.
And thank you for Senate bill
twelve sixty however at that
hearing there was agreement on a
recommendation that sounds are
had not been a fire since
nineteen thirty three there
should be back burning.
And there were countless
environmentalists to them one to
the board of supervisors they
don't live among aceto and then
where the sufferers.
So our our concern is that while
we appreciate twelve sixty we
have the benefit of that
expertise from professionals on
a paid consulting report.
We lack governance seed also are
planning commission listen to
our chief but then nothing
happened and Nash you see we had
a major fire so one of our
concerns as legislatures.
How do we prevent that from
happening again where our local
area says we need back burning
we have a paid fire department?
But then as it goes up the
latter were put into peril I
speak to you in our neighborhood
we been through three fires in
nine years evacuated three
times.
Huge cost to families resulting
and Boris says.
Children that are adversely
affected and we we welcome of
legislation to prevent it our
other question is we'd like to
see legislation so that when
donors gave money we have
several neighbors are willing to
give so significant amounts.
And did but the donations
somehow went into a black hole
we would like to see the local
giving stay local so that there
Tom accountability and
transparency.
We have neighbors in my
community very concerned that
doctors nurses lawyers teachers
who were adversely affected by
that much slow needed to get the
boulders removed.
People were willing to give but
they do know where their money
went so if there's anything you
can do.
For the in the area of
transparency local donors some
of the money went to Santa
Barbara City College for someone
to United Way red cross.
And then people stop giving who
were willing to give more to
help families but there was no
accountability are transparent
parents C..
And then our last question was
how will pending legislation
help the people in this room.
We understand going forward you
have great ideas.
That at the extension are
temporary living expenses what
have you.
But under contract lower
understanding from meeting with
independent insurance adjusters
and with attorneys.
It it then senator Jackson you
know this best ping an attorney
which I'm not.
You can't go retroactive it
would be going forward people in
this room are concerned and we
found that all different
insurance companies such all
different contracts.
But again to to help our
community he'll we'd like to
see.
Something it where not might not
be possible to help them and if
we can't.
Be retroactive then again
through donations or we can
ensure that the people who lived
here before the debris flow on
the fire.
Can return to our community and
then our goal is to make sure
that our first responders live
on this side of wherever disrobe
closure may be.
So that when something happens
we can have all those
firefighters nurses doctors
whoever we need law enforcement
officers.
In our community thank you for
your time.
Well let let me try to answer.
That was a lot of very good
questions.
Our first responders living on
in on the side of the hill
that's a housing issue that's a
real challenge.
What we did here was the pre
positioning so you get this red
flag alert and I remember Friday
evening I was headed toward
carbon via?
And saw all these --
Yes trucks --
Trucks from long fire trucks who
had pre positioned here so arm
onto the housing issue is sort
of a battle on its own --
But certainly it would be very
helpful to people were able to
leave here but that's an issue
that.
Thing is going to take a bunch
of time to to Richard I just
want to add all the vacant house
in Samana C. alike to my
neighborhood there's six on my
street all the people said they
would offer their homes for
first responders to make sure
they could stay.
Here because we know hotels
become commodity were Woodland
Hills were deployed to but maybe
we could have a central place
for people who have three four
eight bedroom homes.
They were willing to make them
available what we didn't know
who to call what to do so that's
just the point perhaps the
county can have of something.
Available to it in terms of
short term or term housing for
first first.
As far as donors --
That's a challenge I know United
Way red cross they accept
contributions a the goal for all
the services so probably the
money that was spent putting in
some of these facilities here
was money that others had given
previously.
Are I think there can be
instances where nonprofits are
set up locally for very specific
purposes they just have to
create them.
And the last thing --
With the the controlled burns
and all up my my measure I. is
designed --
To basically prioritize I and
this will allow cal fire to the
to prioritize based on risk
reduction.
And that's part of what this is
going to be they'll up work with
all stakeholders to plan the
fuel reduction in the least
impactful way --
Including the impact of the
environment but the bottom line
is -- The
choices are between a controlled
small burn or an uncontrolled
big wildfire and obviously we
have got to go for the former.
Rather than the latter that's
the reason I've done the bill
and I think that.
I think we all recognize again
with the nature of these fires
we've gotta do more controlled
burns.
But at and intelligently so
that's my hope.
The the you know and we agree I
think that they a couple things
that I'd like to add in terms of
the housing situation by there
are temporary things that we can
do for short term in and on mid
term.
Housing options for first
responders on this November I.
California will see a couple
ballot initiatives that deal
with housing and on if it is the
hope of this community to see a
long term solution.
When local communities whether
it county or city are developing
housing plans and have housing
initiatives and I would highly
suggest that that voice be?
A voice that's out there we talk
about affordable housing housing
for veterans on and if housing
for first responders is
something the community wants we
may have that opportunity to
think about this in the long
term.
While we experienced it on fire
and for the debris flows it's
not the first time we've
experienced it we also
experienced it for the la
Conchita mudslides.
On and we have we have
consistently seemed at first
responders among also on
education for you know
professionals --
Health professionals I'm are not
living in the communities where
they work and this is one of the
long term consequences of
individuals who cannot afford to
live in the community C. work.
Out so I will say that we will
have an as community the
opportunity to address this if
we go to our cities and also.
To our counties and when housing
projects are being built and ask
is there an opportunity to
include.
XML units in this particular
project for first responders
with considered work for housing
and so I will add that and I
think that that's something that
we can definitely.
Of as well in the future --
In terms of that as someone M.
who chairs the select committee
for the nonprofit sector there's
definitely room to keep having
conversations about donations
and how we keep donations local.
And how we ensure that there's a
network I'm that is able to
provide information at to our
local community that were local
donations are going.
Out I I just wanted to add those
pieces.
I don't have anyone in the
county wants.
I'll go on to the next question
or comment and I think we can
win here and then.
My name is Cindy Marcus and I
want to address your issue of
people signing up for the aware
and prepare I am signed up for
all of them and I was getting.
Loads of alerts and but there
was no phone service a land line
service no cellphone service.
And I was dependent on that I I
was waiting for the alert you to
know what to do and once the
phone service one out there was
no alert we have.
Power we admit.
No nothing so is there something
to do in that certain so --
Yes -- And
part of this hearing that I was
doing in December fourth was to
address the fact that our
wireless services do nothing.
Or very little --
They've got to of be --
Present in this discussion
because Vera fewer and fewer
people are having landline
[inaudible]
And right and so.
I mean land lines we're working
--
Or people were getting notices
that were not accurate --
We need to do we need to create
a twenty first century
technologically appropriate
warning system back in the old
days the warning was the church
bells.
We don't have that anymore but
we do have technology that
should be as effective if not
more effective there's G. O.
fencing that they're talking
about now.
There's also to G. P. S. type
our options are but the private
sector the profit driven private
sector is not particularly
interested in this --
We've got to get their interest
and we're trying to work on that
[inaudible]
Yes.
First a comment then some
comments and questions
[inaudible]
George Bush New Orleans.
Hannah Beth Jackson.
Toni Collette mon and dos
Williams minus ito.
Elections make a difference.
And I thank you all for your
participation.
My first question is monitoring
equipment was mentioned.
Of being stalled.
I'm curious what so.
We're just John that is I do not
think this is the appropriate
time and place for that since
it.
Sounds like it might be quite
extensive.
But I'm hoping that you could
schedule a hearing in the
appropriate humanities.
So the public comment like me
with wacky ideas --
Can come portion present my
wacko ideas --
For example like you know the
oil separation.
How could be done by centrifugal
force rather than?
You know nowadays that don't
work --
Second of all --
I've heard a lot about property
owners and government but I have
not heard anything about
mentors.
I am a member of the rental
housing mediation board for the
city's Santa Barbara.
What's going on with matters you
how are they being assisted
what's what's going on with
that.
Here's my wacko idea.
I watch the planes.
Go into the lake and it.
Scoop up water.
Golden fire scene and dump it.
It seemed to be a little more
ineffective me trying to put out
the fire in my fireplace by
spitting on it.
What I'm thinking is would it
not be cheaper? To have along --
To even though it's five miles
long they could deliver fire
hydrant force in volume --
That local.
No household water supplies
[inaudible]
Cannot.
So I lay that I mean.
Boy those guys sure could use a
lot of water at the scene of the
fire and I think it could make a
significant difference.
If we could transfer the water
that's in the lake. To the fire
expeditiously.
Thanks thank you end it you know
the month this subgroup the
Montecito --
Group whose name I the
resiliency committee I'm sure
would be delighted to hear some
of your comments well that's it
I mean it's just a brainstorm
and have no qualifications to
back up.
Other than being wacko --
We we C. idea.
I think you and I do wanna say
M. I am referencing the document
we have about all the bills that
were introduced in one of those
bills that was introduced by a
colleague in the assembly is
only member would.
I'm was AB nineteen ninety and
the bill prohibits price gouging
of the rental housing that was
not on the market at the time of
the proclamation our declaration
of emergency.
And so currently the like this
for up property that was on the
market I'm during that time and
so this is an expansion I'm of
of protection for renters so I
wanted to mention that that bill
is currently in Senate
appropriations so it's still
alive.
Well I. encourage you to
encourage staff to contact the
rental housing mediation board
--
Mr Fano.
And on safe you can coordinate
you get some kind of notice put
on your publications that this
is a service that is available.
And encouraged us willing to put
the county on the contract.
My name is Lawrence Thompson.
Our local architect.
And since it I. two thousand
thirteen I've been in liaison
with county fire on the idea.
Of putting a fire helicopter
operation.
Right near Marcy.
To because we have over a
hundred miles between sanity and
as and the Ventura county
operations.
And it takes them typically over
half an hour with their ten and
it -- Launch
time. To get down here.
Whereas we have put together an
operation.
That would launch in four
minutes Andy probably anywhere
in Lara Seto wasn't within ten
maybe even eight minutes.
The difference of course is
light years in terms of fire
growth obviously with the Tom
aspire being so well developed
it wouldn't.
Make much difference other than
augmenting the Hartford.
But as with the recent holiday
fire.
And other fires that are do the
Sundowners which need immediate
response it would make a
terrific difference the problem
we're having is.
Money.
The county does not have the
money.
And I understand that in course
even the fire departments who
are operate tremendous effort --
They need more money just to do
what they're doing now.
Yeah so this is the problem I
have one individual who would.
Come up with a half a million
dollars cash to reduce one point
eight million dollar your
project --
But I'd have to match to get him
to bring that money and the
question is.
Is there anything such at the
state level.
Is there anything in terms of
the insurance companies who have
contacted.
Who could join together? To help
augment this we have how many.
Hundred billion dollars for the
real estate here.
And yet we have the RP
helicopters in Santa Ynez.
That's it's very responsible we
have a big county in there right
in the middle.
But as with the Josh hasn't seen
a fire.
They weren't in the Bates at
that time.
And by the time the helicopters
got there the wind was too
strong they couldn't do
anything.
But the response time was like
ninety minutes.
That's a light here.
So.
Might Mike frustration is even
though a she Peterson's Gimme a
kind letter.
I. supporting this says.
Are there other agencies out of
the county.
The Cannella bog Neptis.
And bring us to a point where
the the enormous of
preponderance of work of worth
in terms of property exists
[inaudible]
Thank you.
At you know I I look at our fire
folks and in the back and and
welcome them if they want to
respond I do you want to
describe a little bit about how
state funding works and when
we've been able to share with
you have.
Some additional funding that has
been brought by the state and we
have worked with the county to
identify the priorities --
We work with cities with
counties with our municipalities
to identify what the priorities
are.
And certainly our request being
greater than what we've been
able to and bring to you but and
this does become a challenge for
us that.
We are looking at where we are
where we are at M. also the
direction that being given to us
on at the local level as well in
terms of what those priorities
are.
If that was something that was a
priority for the county F. or
the city it does mean there's
tradeoffs there is nothing that
is done without trade offs.
On we would you know welcome to
how that conversation on a but
that is something that we would
have to that really work with
the county and the cities to
understand where does the
following terms of the priority.
It has been made clear to espy
at I think our local
municipalities at their
priorities at this moment is --
Immediate recovery --
Long term or mid term planning
--
Is something that we're trying
to get to Beth are are
communities have made it very
clear that some of the backfill
on related to so much that has
been lost here is is the
immediate priority.
I'm I don't know if anyone.
I eight think that this is where
we're at certainly I'm if there
are agencies whether it's a
public private private
partnerships that are willing to
explore a and we would be happy
to think about that.
Bombing connect those agencies
should we identify them.
Yeah I think these were all very
excellent suggestions if we have
people who are willing to
contribute but they want to make
sure the money is going.
Where they wanted to go in
[inaudible] To go --
We again.
The whole notion of public
private partnerships is where we
have to go both statewide in
federally it's the you know it's
the public --
Trough gets less and less on the
federal level because of all
these tax giveaways the
reduction of the ability of our
federal government to provide
services is only going to
increase.
Of the state has had a pretty
good run recently but the
economy.
What goes up will come down so
if there are some suggestions
and then again coordinating with
our -- First
responders they know best what
is the most efficient use of
those dollars.
Conversation absolutely worth
having.
We had this one woman here who.
Was wanted to come on up don't
don't be shy.
My name is Lee M. Palmer I'm
actually a good leader resonant
--
First I'd like to think.
Wanders for Friday night.
Was not anything like this but
it wasn't [inaudible]
Good -- In a
poll of over fifty of my
neighbors on the neighborhood.
Out in the area directly
affected I was well as co
workers that live all over town.
We did not receive any alerts we
were all signed up.
Now that one change that has
happened.
Since we all signed up for these
things.
Is the eight oh five issue.
I wonder if anyone has
investigated with however that
worked because when I signed
back up as it all my neighbors
after we got done evacuated and
coming back home and I know it
was small.
Compared to what money Seto went
through but it could have been
worse.
I wonder if anyone has
investigated if Scott affected
us because the only thing that
came through to me was news
hawk.
And I got air every single.
Surveying over this fired the
Whittier fire everywhere so I
wonder about that.
And the second comment I have
is.
I'm old enough to remember and
most people in this room.
The emergency broadcast system
test.
With the obnoxious noise that
used to come over the TV.
Has anyone ever considered.
Before we have the next disaster
to test.
The reverse.
Nine one one the Nick sleep.
The Santa Barbara county.
Do a test notify everybody we're
going to do a test.
And see what happens because you
don't find the holes until the
people are scrambling around in
the dark.
Trying to figure out what
happened.
So since you are on that
committee maybe we can implement
this and maybe if we have
another just faster.
Our community will get timely
notice.
Thank you is shy --
Pulled out the article --
The Tyler Hayden wrote a I guess
it was yesterday --
Very distressing --
And I'm sure the county is going
to take a very deep dive into
that and I will as well
[inaudible]
Because there's really.
Not no excuse for for that
fortunately no one was killed.
Arm the sheriff's office to go
door to door which I think
helped.
Did not go to your door.
Well I have friends that live on
north Fairview in an area I
lost.
Friends who lost their homes.
Nobody went door to door people
fled.
Well I think there was no way
for them to get up there to go
door to door the immediate
neighborhood south.
Of cathedral oaks there were no
deputies going door to door they
were doing the best they can.
They can't go door to door that.
Well I I think that we will be
taking a very hard look at this
I think your suggestion has
merit to it as well.
We do have the technology today
we just have to apply it and I
think those who are very good
questions and thank you for that
thank you.
Any last questions [inaudible]
Rundown.
Hello my name is Jeff harms
Simon twelve forty seven east
Holly wrote.
I'm landscape architect --
I have a question regarding
forest management --
I think that it's something that
actually.
Hit some a lot of these points
here and I think it's really
important --
Well my question is is what kind
of management are we going to go
forward with.
You no we started off with Mike
Smokey the bear management we
all come to know that didn't
work.
And now we're going to the you
know the weed Wacker thing we're
removing everything from the
forest.
But there are more modern ways
of doing in worried too
rewilding things and they
actually proven to work better.
My question is how are we
presenting that rather than
having a knee jerk reaction as
to what we're going to do.
I Wilk presenting that as let's
go forward with the modern way
of doing things of the better
progressive way of doing things
to make things actually work.
And is that part of the
legislation thank.
A I think you for the question
and that is actually the bill
that I am I am authoring EP.
Nineteen fifty six and it's the
year around per I. fire
prevention acts M. that cal fire
chief alluded to and it does
bring --
Experts I'm from academia to
industry to at first responders
to a space to have those
conversations I'm not just in
terms of what the best practices
are in California but looking at
it I'm from the world what have
we seen in other areas of the
world where.
And whether it's a wildfire or
and flood or anything of the
kind what what are the types.
M. of and elements that are
needed to prevent --
These wildfires so I I think you
know it looks it vegetation
management --
On any related educational
outreach on you know fire
prevention strategy defensible
space on retrofitting structures
I to it you know anything that
increases fire resistance.
And so that is something that --
Is going to be state it is
moving forward the bill is still
alive it still has two more
steps.
And before it gets to the
governor's office M. but we do
feel confident that it is
something that will establish
what we used to have in
California which was a working
group.
And reestablish it on the in
collaboration with a number of
other vehicles that are being
used but your points are
absolutely well taken.
And that there are a number
strategies that Smokey the bear
was once our image of fire
prevention on a Bates I. it is.
We have trust me we are far
beyond Smokey the bear who I
still love anything is Q. Anna
but we are far far beyond that
in terms of the strategies and
I'm.
We want to bring that together
at the state level.
And we if that's I think we are
wrapping up.
Think so thank you all very much
for coming up please will share
with us your ideas your thoughts
your concerns that the purpose
of this meeting today --
We are here for you.
Up please make sure you let us
hear from you.
And with that --
Thank you for coming we are
adjourned.